[Musique]
vous voyez ce titre madame je n'invente
rien un ange passe au gouvernement
je crois que ça serait une idée pendant
ce moment parce que tous des eaux il a
eu beaucoup de mal lange qui poste au
gouvernement madame moi ça serait si
chirac raoui il avait raison c'est un
ange oui très ferme j'y crois pas moi je
crois qu aux anges maintenant je vois
dans ce journal la remontée de la
majorité à marseille qu'est ce que ça
signifie
dormez la majorité avant au lieu de 18
ans au lieu de 18 prix voilà un titre je
vous le montrez je le montre la caméra
voilà la barre à gauche moi ça me choque
ça me choque thomas assouan à par la
gauche pourquoi malgré ce qu'il à la
droite il n'est pas à gauche qui ça la
pub à moi j'estime que on ne devrait pas
dire la barre à gauche car monsieur
raymond barre a l'air d'un homme et d'un
homme je sais c'est pas une femme alors
par conséquent on doit le rappeler parce
parent masculin au féminin c'est à dire
qu'il faudrait pas mettre le beurre en
aval à raymond barre à gauche peut-être
n'est pas là d'art pourquoi c'est se
moquer du bien pourquoi mon mais pas la
mitterrand annonce la fin de la campagne
paris qu'est ce que vous en pensez et à
quelques espaces verts qui se réduisent
de plus en plus
on peut pas appeler ça une campagne au
nom d'un groupe vag à paris moi je peux
pas maniable voilà un titre var sort de
sa réserve qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est un peu groupe de pensée
suppresseur de poufs quoi c'est quand
même pas
qu'est ce que c'est que la
bipolarisation est ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer en deux mots la plupart
alisation pour moi cette voie à lummen
chose à voter puis boire l'état hôte
vous rentrez la salle à manger vous
allumez v d'âge on va boucher vavoua
bouton pouvez éteindre en revenir à
s'arranger alors autrement dit la pop
bipolarisation dans les grandes villes
ce serait le système de va et vient un
peu partout exactement cinq ministres
ont été battus même qu'est ce que vous
en pensez moi je dis qu'on ne doit pas
se battre on en parle on peut tout faire
mais pas et pas avec les mains ni rien
du tout qu'est-ce qu'un siège en
ballotage siège à bâle au sage et à suez
abba lancement c'est à lire qui
l'exigent passion française a balance me
correspond au routeur l'expression
anglaise belfort est passé à gauche
belfort était à droite peut pas le faire
penser à vous apprendre la ville à
droite de paris si on peut
comme situation géographie belfort à
droite de l'axé du couple en france en
deux on peut pour le prendre et puis de
faire penser à beaupuy pourquoi si la
chose me de l'hôtel de ville et oui vous
en pensez question de ça je ne peux pas
vous répondre
aux questions de l'histoire de l'autre
au caire je connais l'adresse où ça
s'est passé je me suis là qu'ils
auraient eu les gens réunis vers la mine
la garonne du boulevard
de poker je vous parle de la chaude nuit
de l'hôtel de ville alors la chine y
aura eu au moins six chez quelque chose
je me permet de garder le secret
professionnel vous étiez au courant vous
même oui
[Musique]